556 on your monday morning we're putting
a bow on all the talk about those wide
open spaces between cars you know last
time we heard about distancing to keep
from maybe having to pay other people's
bills after stoplight crashes one guy
just looking for some shade in the heat
i got three more emails to share about
this subject that really touched a nerve
we'll start with michael got some not so
kind words for drivers from our
neighbors to the south only people from
california sit on everyone's bumper it's
their way of life so they can get more
cars on the freeway now they're doing it
here then there's terry who writes this
situation is possibly a subconscious
transference of drivers social
distancing might sound funny but i think
people go into a subconscious mode and
do things they don't realize they're
doing ps i'm not a psychologist that's
just my two cents and we're going to
close with linda who maybe nailed it on
why the wide open spaces in a hurry to
stop and text everyone's head is looking
down at their crotch at a signal it's so
obvious thanks to all of you who emailed
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there is something
driving you crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com